in addition to her acting career Denise
Richards is also an accomplished model
she started modeling as a teenager and
was successful enough to travel the
world for photo shoots and commercials
once her acting career took off she
spent less time modeling but still made
time to pose in the gala Christmas issue
of Playboy magazine in 2004. Richards
had given birth to her oldest daughter
Sammy just months before the photo shoot
her husband at the time Charlie Sheen
was a Playboy fan and encouraged her to
be in the magazine but she had her own
reasons for doing it as well Richard's
revealed to US Weekly in 2011 I wanted
to encourage women that it's okay to
embrace your sexuality even though
you're a mom